how everyone you may have noticed I  haven't been uploading any videos this  week that's because I'm on a holiday  here at the English seaside enjoying  some English cuisine of course some  chips here now while there's no videos  to watch this week you might want to go  and check out a new channel I've just  started all about the science of food  it's cold food ski it's also on Twitter  on Facebook  basically we're covering the chemistry  physics the biology of the stuff that we  eat and drink and again this projects  been done with experts at the University  of Nottingham so if it sounds like  something you might enjoy go and  subscribe to the channel for now I'm  going to finish my chips and then I'm  heading back to Nottingham it'll be  business as usual next week  let me know what you think of my wife's  camerawork as well